Hachi Machi that middle class famous
tour is in full swing get Perino you
ain't lying fatty it's a live comedy
show we play a little ayg with the crowd
great way to introduce people to the
show bring the squad come out and see us
we're coming baby yeah gang these
tickets are selling quickly uh so make
sure you get your tickets we're coming
in uh we're gonna be Red Bank New Jersey
then we're going to Seattle Portland all
in August then in September we're going
Kansas City Springfield St Louis then
we're going down into Nashville hitting
Indy coming home to Philly baby the
chicken's got to come home to roost then
we're hitting Providence Rhode Island up
there to Beantown get those tickies
let's go welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
favorite new podcast this is our you you
garbage oh yeah little show we sit down
your favorite comedians and we find that
the girl to be classy yeah don't they
just a big old piece of trash I'm your
host takes Foley coming at you on a
sweltering Day hot down here at antuti's
basement I go into that broad's room
she's got two [ __ ] window units in
there yeah it's like a sheets in that
place okay I told her [ __ ] you open
the door share the love it's like a
walk-in [ __ ] pouring sweat in my room
I feel like I'm an episode of mash my
co-host is coming at you from across the
table he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is
an international businessman he is not
to be trifled with in the Board Room or
the bedroom yeah and he really stinks up
the bathroom I can tell you that give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan Hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure your rate review subscribers
over there on iTunes please full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are
good just crossed 80 000 of them
[ __ ] love it the army of
garbage grows and we love you and we
appreciate it new troops every day what
else is that it uh patreon
the weekly episodes of ayg weekly
episodes of hard feelings which is
arguably better than ayg uh and when we
do we just crossed our we just did the
Tony family reunion Dave and Buster's
actually out by the time this is out of
here
kidding also we got Camp it's not lined
up we're gonna be going camping in two
weeks it's gonna be a whole [ __ ]
thing we got Disney coming up too busy
we had to reschedule Disney but it's
coming up we got some other cool things
and it works yeah so do us a favor get
over there to the patreon check it out
it's a good time and how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire very funny stand-up New
York City comedian we love them you
[ __ ] love them he crosses the t's he
dots the eyes he works the ones and twos
give it up for T-Bone McMuffin Toby
McMullen everybody what up dudes PR pal
yeah we're gonna pop a fire hydrant or
what dude
as [ __ ] some are in the city baby get
myself arrested so I can cool off at the
[ __ ] Rikers for a couple hours
let's do it this is [ __ ] ridiculous
ah it [ __ ] sucks dude [ __ ] crazy
out there man man sweating plus you
gotta [ __ ] beg the Uber guys to
[ __ ] tourney they get real [ __ ]
chintzy with it oh you cracked that
window it's [ __ ] they put the heat on
it's like come on man trying to get the
best of both worlds I'm paying for
premium and like I what
I'm putting a bill on you
I see you rolling around in a [ __ ]
Escalade like [ __ ] like you're Joe
Biden that happened one time and it was
a movie premiere and I wanted to impress
my one
are you in this no I'm not nobody
interviewed the guy who was in it uh Liz
snubs you
he signs my head
shout out to Joe listings
he loved the movie and that [ __ ]
feature film Fourth of July if you
haven't seen it do yourself a [ __ ]
favor and check it out it's phenomenal
how many Ubers did you take in the past
48 hours I would like to know because I
don't I don't keep tabs this is more
hard feelings I don't keep tabs on you
but there was a lot of a lot of a lot of
Henry charges those records are sealed I
can't just [ __ ] tell everybody that
what are you talking about Toby switch
over to patreon real quick hit this way
please switch over
I am not happy
oh I'm like Kylie Jenner [ __ ] float
around three minute flights
did you have a helicopter in the Bronx I
want to go to the game I'm taking blade
back and forth to the stairs oh no it's
funny funny funny funny but
um we uh I went to uh I went to I don't
go to a lot of events right I went to a
UFC event
um and uh this was a dirtbag move did
you win
this is me versus a hot dog
I got mustard all over me also shout out
to the [ __ ] Army garbage it was in
attendance baby yeah I mean a UFC fight
in Long Island is our demo by the way
but you know
they hand you a belt
but uh
this is what I I didn't think of this
and we went with our good friend Brian
and he was like uh shout out to B Morton
he goes so we get there and he goes
you want you know what you want to do I
go what's that he goes we had already
had really good seats tell them you're a
cut man and getting the ring
yeah you brought your bucket right Kip
I'm like what the [ __ ] soap this pork
chop real quick see how good you are and
maybe we've met I don't know he said you
get to your seats right and then you
pull out StubHub and see what's unsold
so you can move closer but you've
already paid for your seat
yeah but we were we had really good
seats Oh Oh you mean not pay for the new
seats no just see what's available that
way you know no one's gonna come and sit
there holy [ __ ] and I was like wouldn't
they shoe you back anyway what do you
mean wouldn't the ushers we were on the
floor right but like they don't know
where they just let once you're on the
floor it's kind of wherever your seats
but like they're not checking every
aisle okay so like if I if you look and
be like oh the third Row's open you can
just walk up [ __ ] yeah we're seats 12
13 and 14 and you know those tickets
aren't sold yeah they don't do that [ __ ]
up in the Bronx man they'll [ __ ]
Yankee out of there like a [ __ ] high
school kid yeah Steinbrenner don't play
no yeah no just trying to get close to
Aaron judge but that's happening that
was like holy [ __ ] I was like that's a
[ __ ] solid it's nice that's [ __ ]
sneaky that's something I can get behind
no I didn't have the ball I was getting
recognized I couldn't get thrown out at
the same time you moved here you moved
two three seats back just to be safe
that's awesome yeah all right gang
there's a family episode sure as you
know when you sign up for the old
patreon there we answer your questions
right here live on here on here and
we're gonna do that right now
Kevin James
[Laughter]
we might have to turn the AC on he's
[ __ ] over eating oh holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
any windshield wiper fluids his brain's
gonna be bubbling me down a little bit
you ever pee in a radiator what no I
don't know
where did you grow up dude
never robbed banks in the 20s pee on a
radio here what's that get you because
it's too hot what yeah you pee in it if
you're out of water in the in the
radiator what are you doing in the house
I think just for the weekend I didn't
know see when the boys are [ __ ]
they're letting loose I I genuinely
thought you meant like the air
conditioner on the side of the house or
something no but I have scratched those
things scratching the coils
that's a good way to get Patty to give
you a right hook yeah [ __ ] start
scratching at that like I got yelled at
and I'm like that [ __ ] doesn't [ __ ]
matter you got yelled I think it does
seal something up no it doesn't feels
real good it doesn't uh yeah I used to
put like you use your thumb to put your
initials in there or something it said
kjrim I was like you [ __ ] suck I'm like
it wasn't me for a good time call Denise
ah it's good stuff ah yeah shout out
that's uh that was a [ __ ] great
Pastime you know what else I had in the
front of our house we had that big green
humming box the [ __ ] was that the
I don't know like the big green power
but I don't know I still don't know yeah
that's new neighborhood [ __ ] it's a
Transformer yeah that's new neighborhood
hippie in Disguise
fat little [ __ ]
sitting on the couch
not playing sports or scoring with
chicks he sits there and watches this
show how old was I
if I was if I was eight it'd be weird if
I was scoring with chick you could be
laying some groundwork out there
pressing the flesh a little bit how you
doing I'm Gippy in three years I'm going
to want to [ __ ] you
ah yeah that was new neighborhood [ __ ]
you saw that [ __ ] in the neighborhood I
got jealous that and retaining punch you
really said in your retaining puns was a
sign of a wealthy neighborhood sign of a
basement no a basement I'm talking about
in the neighborhood sure I thought I had
to do something with basements and
flooding and like the water table or
something I knew we couldn't afford it I
could tell you that you guys couldn't
afford a hole in the ground I could sump
pump City over there we used to go
swimming in them in a big flood but you
would just have to stay away because
that whole that [ __ ] that hole from
it was in there the sewer catch the
whirlpool oh man I don't [ __ ] we used
to get inner tubes and boogie boards and
[ __ ] end up in Haiti
hey
yeah that's like the upside down that
was [ __ ] frightening I remember doing
that at the time being like we shouldn't
be doing oh 100 anytime we had a strong
rain uh hurricane season it was like
having a pool in your backyard
[ __ ] partying we had the creek over
at Town Line townhouse how did you call
it a creek or a crick Crick is the
trashiest word in the in it's not in the
trashiest word in America is Crick a
crick down the creek no we said Creek I
think yeah
we did fish for uh little crawdads
though they were everywhere couldn't eat
them but still pick them up I tried
still pick them up and play with them
crawl dads yeah Blue Bell Pennsylvania
I'm telling you we had these little tiny
lobsters that were in the creek I swear
to God man little [ __ ] Jimmy John's
you [ __ ] pick them up and hold them
up just stick them in a girl's face
[ __ ] throw them back but that thing
would flood it ran down the whole side
of the property and then it it hit a
road and had the the sewer that went in
there sure
there was a great on the other side that
would like catch leaves and [ __ ] or
[ __ ] little Timmy if it gets sucked
in there if you went in there it was
[ __ ] yeah start splitting up the
baseball cards
he ain't gonna need it where he's going
yeah yeah it was [ __ ] frightening and
it would like proper [ __ ] flood and
have a strong current and we'd be in
there [ __ ] swimming not to mention
what kind of [ __ ] chemical runoff is
in there yeah
[ __ ] crazy
strengthen your immune system though
yeah but never in a retaining pond oh
yeah you were a gentleman you were in
the cricket we didn't have that kind of
money the Blue Bell lobsters yeah he
[ __ ] scumbag
couldn't eat them I saw a lady swimming
in the East River the other day I'm so
upset you're not allowed I'm gonna do it
I'm so [ __ ] mad it's so hot out right
now and we're on an island and you can't
this is hell this is what hell is I I
was thinking about that when we were in
Staten Island the [ __ ] one time I jumped
in the Hudson it's gonna kill me what
about Sully sullenberger those guys were
all right here's the middle of winter
too they weren't swimming though they
got wet they got wet
they got wet they took a shower
afterwards they weren't tubing it's not
hell I'll hold my nose put a cork in my
head I don't think why so it's the
weekend
that's how the eels get in there if you
pay them enough you wouldn't be afraid
of something going up there yeah in the
East River anyway no they eat oh yeah
I'm always scared oh by the way good
luck getting me in the [ __ ] ocean
with all these [ __ ] shark attacks
doing drive-bys and [ __ ] out in [ __ ]
Long Island it's [ __ ] insane yeah I'm
out I'm out for good okay cool climate
change really takes it all away I ain't
going in the water talk about this we
might have mentioned it on a patreon
episode okay but there's been more
attacks
and I'm not [ __ ] doing it you're
never going to the ocean again never
going to the ocean again okay now and I
don't know about Lakes either damn this
is nuts too and I have this picture and
I'll try to find it it was always it was
always folklore of my uncle was out
fishing shout out to my uncle John my
uncle John was out fishing and they
caught a wrestled an orca no they caught
like
I think a shark like another shot like a
you know small [ __ ] tiger shark they
caught a big fish which I believe was a
shark I forget or like a Marlin or
something and they have it at the back
of the boat right and they're like you
know they they gaffed it it comes up you
[ __ ] hook it and you're like sitting
there those things are tough to get on
the boat so you like they're all you
always drag them for a little bit once
it gets to the boat and tire them out
they're sitting there [ __ ] taking
pictures of it right like old school
like film picture like a disposable
camera or something and as he's taking a
bunch of pictures a [ __ ] great white
comes up and eats it so you see it like
kind of come out I saw the pic I posted
them on Facebook somewhere years ago
because this and I never [ __ ]
believed it and then they were like
moving or something he goes here are
these pictures and it's literally call
me a liar little [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
bald-headed 12 year old yeah [ __ ] that
they come out and eating the whole [ __ ]
it was it was it was just like the head
of the [ __ ] Marlin or whatever
no no see where Bluebell Crick
be careful out there Patty Pennsylvania
Lobster yeah man [ __ ] all that [ __ ] I
ain't doing it there's something going
on I don't know if it's climate change
whatever it is yeah they're getting
ballsy they're coming in close there's
something with the fresh water and the
rain water into this and that and I'm
out yeah but how many people swim in the
Atlantic Ocean a day it doesn't matter
it does have millions millions of people
not Millions how many people what couple
hundred
it's millions of people go either way
look how many shark attacks there's been
in the last uh it's literally a month
yeah it's still like one out of
how many people swim in the ocean
hundreds of millions a month doesn't
matter and if there's one a month that's
one in a hundred million it's gonna keep
getting worse they're gonna be coming on
land soon as soon as they can start
driving we're in real trouble sticking
you up steal your wallet
start hacking but
the East River and the surrounding water
of Manhattan has always bothered me I
saw a family swimming in the
in the Hudson one time like playing like
the kids had like rubber duckies that's
dangerous I know it's the current it's
not the pollution although I think GE
the little did a little number on the
Hudson River in the 70s no it's not it
well the pollution is you're not allowed
to eat crap you're only allowed to eat
like six crabs a month out of the East
River that dude if you're eating [ __ ]
crabs that have a lemon on it like that
dude switch to the fake stuff it ain't
that bad yeah that's not like a Maryland
Blue Crab shout out to him got into
Chester River there a little bacon pull
them right out
that's what they eat on give them bacon
you give crabs bacon you put it in a
little cake down there no that's real
Dirtbag [ __ ] what are you using bunker
what's bunker Bait fish for crab nah nah
use bacon where do crabs eat bacon are
they going to the diner what what are
you talking about they've only had bacon
because you've given them bacon yeah
that's right it's meat there you go get
the mate we get the maple [ __ ] syrup
Chum
I got that candy
[Laughter]
[ __ ] what are you doing no the
currents in the East River uh are really
bad because the water is like fighting
each other it's fresh water and salt
water mixing together that's further
down right I think it's all around the
island yeah
plus they got them tankers out suck you
off uh as of July 20th there have been
49 shark attacks in 2022. that's not six
fatal eight provoked
what's up [ __ ] what are you a nurse
jerk
you know you even have teeth
hey your mom's a hammerhead dork
[ __ ] you say [ __ ] yeah get out of here
provoked who's what the talking about
walking around in a bad neighborhood
I was hanging on a coral reefs
I want 20 ATM I shouldn't have two of
them are UPS guys just trying to do
their job dude what the [ __ ] man six
fatal now dude six out of a hundred
million people that have gone swimming
and that number might be inflated but 40
million people have swam in the [ __ ]
think about how many people are Wildwood
alone sharks don't go there
sharks don't eat Porter yeah they're all
drunk then there's no meat on those legs
end up catching herpes everybody's on
dialysis
but it is crazy that we haven't built
something in Brooklyn on the water on
the shoreline or in Manhattan on the
shoreline where you swim in the river
but you block it out I think it's
pollution is it I think so man because
in Hawaii they have these [ __ ]
management they have those everywhere
yeah I mean like you go to like the Dr
somewhere they have like they have it
not at all so the [ __ ] Sharky's this
is still scary though man let me get in
there and look they get through what we
call In The Biz a [ __ ] they get through
yeah I don't like that they'll get
through yeah they do no they jump at
night [ __ ] deep blue sea Where They
smash the [ __ ] window
when did that that's a good movie shout
out to hello Cool J did he may he didn't
make it in that right it was the only
guy spoiler alert he was the only guy to
make it him in the parrot I think
because he didn't do it him and the
white guy who looks like uh
every other white guy that this was in
those movies he didn't do too good in
Anaconda that was Ice Cube just picked
up that is big yeah one of my favorite
lines ever he didn't make it ice cube
yeah he did he survived have you seen
any movie I believe him and JLo made it
okay Jon void on the other hand yeah I
see it coming though goddamn LeBaron he
was looking for trouble
provoking he got eaten
yeah right and then opened up right he
was in it alive at like they cut open
the snake or it spit him back up and he
was alive did he eat him again I think
it's a documentary right no yeah
watch that again tonight
my summer viewing uh all right let's get
into so it is I mean I'm sure this is a
hacky premise but it is [ __ ] up they
run shark week in July
he had to scare everybody yeah who's
doing that big shark I don't get it they
want because you're you're the shark
Lobby nobody gives a [ __ ] about sharks
at [ __ ] after Thanksgiving you gotta
[ __ ] do it when people are [ __ ]
scared that's why they tuned in because
they want that fear can't but it's
talking about that manscaped manscape
Best In The Biz best in the business The
Only In The Biz I would say for below
the waist grooming here's a here's a
bombshell I'm about to drop on it hit me
are you familiar with the new Platinum
package what are we doing the 4.0
Platinum package they got it all Yes uh
the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmers included
the weed whacker nose and ear hair
trimmer which a lot of you bozos need by
the way need some clippings uh the
features
something word I can't pronounce
Advanced Skin safe technology to protect
your delicate parts and dietary yeah I
got caught up in the moment both are
waterproof so you can shave in the
shower or in the pool like me ah don't
forget to reply they're aluminum free
that's big you don't want to get those
uh you don't get cancer aluminum Free
Ultra Premium deal oh can't you do you
[ __ ] and also wrap your head in tin
foil uh deodorant for that cologne
quality scent on the go
this isn't your daddy's dracar Noir baby
this is real nice I got all but good I
got their body wash that I've been going
through fantastic they send us all the
stuff I got shirts I got on these I got
body wash they're the best shout out to
manscape they're awesome the Platinum
package 4.0 covers all of your bases
from head to toe get 20 off here's the
turkey baby I ain't talking 510 I'm
talking 20 off and free shipping with
code garbage at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
use promo code garbage at checkout it's
time you enjoy the Finer Things in life
do it okay let's talk about bespoke
posts you mean that goddamn box awesome
summertime grilling season you want cool
stuff you want to look cool when you're
Outdoors when you go hiking you want to
look like a bozo City Slicker no you
need cool [ __ ] cool gear gotta have a
cool pocket knife you gotta have a cool
Compass you gotta have cool grooming
stuff cool grilling stuff cool stuff for
the house the box of awesome has it all
do yourself a [ __ ] favor yeah guys uh
to get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers are going to
help them pick out the right box there
you go for you there you go they release
new boxes every month across a ton of
different categories each box is valued
at around 70 dollars but you only pay a
fraction at a price uh plus with box of
awesome you're supporting small business
90 of everything that comes in your box
of awesome is from a small up and coming
brand
best thing it's free to sign up you can
skip any month or cancel at any time
call to action baby here we go the
turkey get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at boxofawesome.com
enter the code garbage at checkout
that's box of awesome.com go garbage for
20 off your first box box of boston.com
promo code garbage not back this year
uh all right guys as the big man stated
this is a family episode we answer your
questions from the patreon your garbage
questions uh we get a [ __ ] ton of
submissions email [ __ ] DMs I mean
somebody knocked on my door the other
day and was like hey is it garbage to
[ __ ] shove Mayo up your ass I said
[ __ ] hey mailman get out of here uh
but the patreon gets first crack at it
this one very on topic we're the king of
Segways over here this naturally happens
this one's from Scotty B Scotty B have
you ever smoked a cig in the ocean yeah
[ __ ] yeah I don't think I have I've
definitely done the lake and probably
the bay I don't know if I've ever done
in the ocean Sandbar Kaneohe Bay Oahu
Hawaii oh all right [ __ ] ripping
heaters and sucking down white claws
okay and eating these Korean barbecue
ribs these little little half ribs that
have these little delicious I'm not
gonna lie
cook them right there on the pontoon
boat yeah they throw them out to you
then you throw the little bones into the
water let the let the turtles get it
they love it you know what that does
yeah here we go we're full circle it is
the smoker's dream to have that
really good like you're like I'm doing
something relaxing I should also do this
right like I double it up a heater in a
pool heater in a pool is all right try
in your hands ah but it's they're never
dry enough
and you're like you know I go when I go
into Paddy's pool I keep my arms up
I go over there on the Windows wow if I
walk in there like a surgeon [ __ ] and
then set my little stuff up over there
on the side there on the side rail put
the umbrella up [ __ ] repeaters yeah
cigs a signal pull good
you can't throw it in the ocean though
that's a bad look okay ripping a butt
[ __ ] flipping it we yeah then they
find turtles and [ __ ] with [ __ ] a
half a pack of palm malls in them I'm
not condoning this but in the 90s we
littered a lot off of boats we just
didn't know better and we were told that
salt dissolves it or eats it really yeah
I mean there was no scientist on board
but
Bill Nye wasn't wasn't the captain
you're throwing old bikes out there no
of course you would rip a Coors like you
grip the core is like throwing beer cans
in the ocean yeah check to see if that
dissolves what are you [ __ ] no it
doesn't are you sure no apple eats
everything maybe over 30 years whatever
holy [ __ ]
that's kind of what we used to go deep
sea fishing too like way out way way
like [ __ ] I mean not there uh that's
what I'm saying I mean I wasn't I wasn't
doing it in the pool
how long does it take for a Coors Light
can oh aluminum whether in a can or
cooking utensil is protected by a thin
aluminum oxide coating that adheres very
strongly and is extremely resistant to
dissolving in seawater yeah these were
different cans
I said Tunica
we'd rub the aluminum off
what's this I heard about you breaking a
rake and throwing in the woods no
The Rake was broken so I returned it to
its home uh Billy Madison Gilmore but we
used to go out
you go you would it would freak it's
real Eerie you get out there I'm talking
like
you drew for like four hours out four
hours you're out there out like the
canyon
the great Continental can or whatever
the [ __ ] they are elephants toss Canyon
or something you're like out there so
it's like the cotton so it's like
whatever and then drops
to like you know I like a million
fathoms or something like it like to
like
the RF Buckley yeah what are you talking
about I'm an article man at the end of
the day
um
and you troll the forehead was 40
fathoms but that's also like the inner
coastway or whatever the Intercoastal
Waterway is not that far out I know
whatever Jet Stream whatever everything
meets there kind of so it's like the
water's coming up from Florida so you
just everywhere like there's just like
[ __ ] it would be like a baby doll's head
and it's like real [ __ ] there'd be
like a [ __ ] just wild [ __ ] floating
out the water slides down there feel
like looking around like what the [ __ ]
dude four hours out yeah man that's
you're done something happens out there
yeah I mean what do you mean something
happens I don't know a fight on the boat
well I mean no I beat them you have like
radios if the boat went down four hours
they could get these I know but they
have one of those like [ __ ] you know
Chopper it looks like a duffel bag you
[ __ ]
it looks like a duffel bag and you pull
a stroke full of weed
yeah a little [ __ ] uh it's not a
little but it pops up and it holds like
eight people like eight days you know
what lifeboats are sweet the ones on the
cargo ships they're like they look like
little submarines okay the one that
Captain Phillips was in at the end ooh
those things are nice yeah that I
wouldn't I just watched that documentary
on Pearl Harbor yeah
a couple guys dropped the ball over
there it was a lot
they're like I saw 78 planes coming in
but I thought it was something else like
what do you mean something else
I thought the air show was starting to
do the Blue Angels come on [ __ ]
taking Heavy Artillery fire over here
John
ah [ __ ] that four hours out at Sea yeah
you really find out who you are
especially the guy who's driving the you
know a little boost up but there's
nothing to hit out there so you're
pretty good
except for baby doll heads oh yeah I
don't like that you know you could find
you see like propane tanks floating and
[ __ ] like it like just like a wild
amount of trash well there's that thing
the trash island off the coast of
[ __ ] Birds always ranting about it
you ever looked that thing up yeah it's
pretty wild yeah it's ugly I I would say
the worst part about getting on a boat
is when you get the extra life vest from
underneath and it's all beer stained
molding cold and wet I don't mind that
cold and wet what do you already go down
once no it's everything on a bullet like
in those like [ __ ] storage containers
and holes in the holes I feel like those
things kill you the life vest I'd want
to be loose
let's do the mashed potatoes
like squeezing my neck holding me up I
feel like you're just like a [ __ ]
olive floating in a [ __ ] Martini for
a shark to get you I want to see stick
and move please give me a fighting
chance against them what I can Wade
now you couldn't wait for more than 10
minutes that's not true at all I'm very
buoyant someone yeah someone just did
this though I think the bar stool just
did it the guy lasted like like it's
like wildly hard really yeah you you
have to you constantly use every muscle
in your body for that whole time
all right yeah
anywho uh this one's from Shane is it
garbage if my girlfriend's father still
cuts her hair he's a retired doctor and
she's 25. what the [ __ ] that's something
you have a bowl cut something's weird
with that that's weird hey it's weird
you're dating abroad with a high-end
tight what are the sides and three on
the top that's nuts yeah how could he do
a good job
I think it's more
sexual it's just I'm not sexual but
emote something that's weird that's
that's a weird Bond that's a weird
connection Patty cut my hair once or
twice then I cut my own one time yeah
that was that for that I told you I got
my I had my made my mom put a number one
in the back of my head one summer
because I was number one
she did a pretty good job I gotta give
it to her she freehanded the whole thing
on the deck
that's crazy damn dude [ __ ] that's
weird that's yeah you should knock that
was I mean if she must have some
strike real basic kind of haircut
he's not like [ __ ] giving her a
blowout and [ __ ] like that putting color
in yeah maybe I mean if he was a retired
salon owner okay what a [ __ ]
pediatrician or whatever and that's
[ __ ] that's garbage yeah also like
I I don't know you know I feel like
that's also with the women that's a big
uh you know it's a big deal who does
your hair let's go oh you used Tiffany I
go to Marco blah blah blah you know
expensive as [ __ ] my dad does it in the
garage you're like what the [ __ ] yeah
that's crazy yeah those those ladies
haircuts are [ __ ] really something
else two tree four hundred dollars
[ __ ] highlights this and that blow
dry snip cut [ __ ] great ends whatever
mm-hmm I always always wanted somebody
to do or I guess I always wanted to do
like you get like the straight razor and
like thin it out yeah I have that I get
that done really yeah wow I get that can
I do it patreon come on let me do it one
time slice my throat
you never loved me [ __ ] Sweeney Ryan
over here
[ __ ] hitting my karate I'm out
those are pretty good videos what were
they where they have somebody in the
barber chair Let Me Burn it let me let
me do like the get the [ __ ] out of here
those Middle Eastern dudes doing [ __ ]
tighten you up now what am I doing this
[ __ ] Super Cuts in Mumbai are you
[ __ ] nuts no we're not doing that why
no when when they have the guy close his
eyes and they and they're shaving his
neck and they pretend like they cut him
with a straight razor oh the guy's
always pass out it's awesome yeah what
and they freak out they're like oh my
God all right that you could do but
you're not setting my hair on I mean you
would know if I did it then yeah exactly
I'd still be able to convince you I
killed you I think
uh all right let's see here this one's
for Matt C shout out to Matt who I
recently uh just met have you ever taken
someone else's cash tip that was left on
the bar and passed it to the bartender
as your own tip that's a dirt ball move
well I wouldn't call it dirt what are
you somebody else's what yes that's
stealing
uh what are you a saint all of a sudden
I'm not doing that [ __ ] doing what [ __ ]
[ __ ] stealing somebody's tips and
passing it off as my own and what does I
guess that guy screwed you here you go
yeah it's that guy's problem nah that's
[ __ ] up that's not even garbage that's
trash yeah next question have you done
that yeah I've done that I've been a
poor alcoholic
I bet I tell you what I've done it not
bartenders catch you doing that they're
[ __ ] fuming no all right I did it not
too long ago I remember a couple of guys
[ __ ] [ __ ] up uh at martells when I
used to work there taking tips off the
bar and the [ __ ] bartenders taking
tips off the bar is different I would
never take a tip off the bar it's still
the same thing no it's not I mean it's
up there it's you're I'm just tricking
you to think I tipped and that guy
didn't there I didn't touch the money I
didn't do anything you're still
theoretically taking their money no no
because you're not giving your [ __ ] I'm
setting an illusion
that that money was mine that's
different take it from behind their ear
is this your quarter
uh I did I was at a comedy club I was at
a comedy I was working I was poor man
what do you want from me and
the somebody had left like a 20 he paid
with a 50 and left to 20 or something
and I was eating and drinking 10 for me
and ten from him I was my dad by the way
I've seen all I'm on stage
I forget exactly the mechanics of it but
he thought I had left it for him ah and
he goes yep I remember this thank you so
much man holy [ __ ] I just doing my part
like it took me a half a second you know
and I was like ah
you've been working hard take it you
know what I mean that's for yo I did you
know what give me five back how about
that can you break this for me
quarters oh yeah that's for you okay
um I did pull the move at Dave and
Busters though but here we go that guy
had a bucket out the bartender had a bug
how did you tip that guy I didn't I said
well take care at the end I assume you
you you whacked them at the end with the
card I'm not gonna lie I was yeah I did
no he did okay he did he's like there's
a tip on that already and I tipped on 50
cash when we got there nice to make them
play ball yeah I didn't want to but it
was all I had from spot pain there you
go yeah I said here that's for you and
then he was Johnny on the spot with the
bus Johnny on the spot yeah he was all
right and then he's like there's an 18
tip included nice so there you go okay
cool but I thought I would take care at
the end all right no cash on me that's
real deal I mean you're wearing
basketball shorts it's real Dirtbag [ __ ]
but while it's in my suit I apologize
um
this one is from Rabia ali rabaya uh
first time long time homie do you call
it ground beef or hamburger meat
[Laughter]
hamburger meat dude yeah all day I'm a
hamburger meat man myself I'll get some
hamburger meat I told you upstate that
called Hamburg gets her some hamburg
meat in there yeah that's [ __ ] burger
meat hamburger meat is sitting sounds
like you can't read
[Laughter]
it literally sounds like that
that's like someone who's just moved
here and is learning the language and
has to like peace that's how I feel like
I said when I go to another country and
I can like piece together what I call
pork pig meat yeah maybe some big meat
oh yeah Hamburg hamburger meat was
[ __ ] brought out of the freezer
before mom left went to work she put it
in a [ __ ] silver bowl half filled
with water in the sink and that's where
it sat and I came home after she left to
make my Hamburger Helper yeah shout out
to the stroganoff flavor
just me and Patty my brother was off at
school my dad was on the road we were
talking about this the other day we
somebody had brought up Hamburger Helper
God damn and then there's other helpers
correct yeah tuna which supposed to be
that's the TR like turkey helper or
something turkey helpers okay tuna tuna
help
any deviation Hamburger Helper is shitty
I'm not saying it's not good it's not a
[ __ ] Michelin Star product
okay
then they might have won one year you're
one it was runner-up you're watering
that down with turkey helper [ __ ]
tuna helper Chicken Helper tuna helper's
pretty bad Hamburger Helper works
because it's HH
that's true
turkey helper doesn't sound like it's so
[ __ ] good man you know when that
cools down to where you can just scarf
it down out of the pan you know I used
to do that oh [ __ ] yeah you know what I
was a big out of the pan guy the [ __ ]
Rice-A-Roni or those nor noodles when
[ __ ] put the words right out of my
mouth the north noodles will congeal a
little bit oh you can cut them with a
knife eat like eat them like a gentleman
yeah right out of the [ __ ] out of the
pot Rice-A-Roni with the long spaghetti
in there versus Versailles vermicelli
vermicelli the vermicelli sound like
somebody who lived next door to us
sounds like mice Tony vermicelli I
always thought it sounded like mice
Vermeil I don't know what it is is it
vermicelli pharmaceutical yeah no it
sounds like vermicelli Toyota shout out
to him
but the savings are thin
whoa hey there's no bad ideas that one
was bad trying to get a campaign off the
ground here
um all right this one hold on a second
that's a [ __ ] home run Homer that was
a [ __ ] killer man home run hamburger
meat sounds so trashy shout out to rabby
but I don't know what else you would
oh yeah it's hamburger ground beef I
know but well your meatballs the the I
didn't eat meatballs till about 28 years
old
you didn't like meatballs I didn't eat I
didn't eat red meat for a very long time
God damn yeah I'm a weird kid man you
wonder why you're bad you had no iron in
you
Jesus Christ
let's talk about factor factor Summer's
gonna start winding down soon things are
gonna start getting busy you're gonna
you're not gonna have a lot of time you
want to keep your your weight loss goals
you want to keep going to the gym you
want to keep eating right you want to be
self-prepared a favor yeah get factor
involved if you're having a quick bite
at the office before a big meeting oh
when you get home and you're tired they
have their pre-made ready to go meals
delivered right to your door we love
them they're fantastic I recommend the
marsala Factor makes lunch and dinner on
busy days at total Breeze their fresh
oven never frozen meals are delivered
nice uh ready to heat and eat and too
heat and eat in two minutes baby so you
can fuel up and get back on track for
the day listen this is no BS we were
Factor guys before they ever yeah we
learned about advertising on the show
big factor to come to the house you set
them up by the bank you throw them open
it's easy peasy I love it shout out to
the chicken farm because he likes a nice
chicken they got a massive Factor they
got a mashed cauliflower knock your
socks it's good it's the right portion
you don't go over it's fantastic in fact
Factor now offers 30 plus meals per week
and 33 add-on options like smoothies
juices snacks there you go uh something
the guy you keep you moving all day new
Gourmet plus meals make eating at home
feel extra special I will put on a nice
plate and feel real fancy light a candle
there you go
um they're made to made and prepared to
Perfection by Factor chefs and ready to
eat in record time so you can Savor the
flavor baby and not stress on the prep
yeah it's real quick in a micro it is
Boom ready to go not only do Factory
meals save time they also keep us
satisfied and the chef crafted recipes
are packed with extra restaurant quality
flavor it's so good I had to go dot
factor75.com garbage 130. one more time
head to go dot
factor75.com garbage 130 use promo code
garbage one three zero and get 130
dollars
go dot
factor75.com garbage 130 use code
garbage 130 to get a hundred and thirty
dollars off across six boxes crazy
that's code garbage 130 at go dot
factor75.com garbage 130 for 130 off the
link will be in the description do it
now back to the show back to the show
our meatball normally the traditional
meatball is like 30 pork thirty percent
veal Thirty twenty or whatever no no not
the fat content the the it's three
different Meats okay it's like it's
squirrel
yeah I know you mean yeah yeah our
meatballs for most of my life Patty was
just there were just little they were
just round hamburgers that's how she did
it with some breadcrumbs in it same
thing with her meatloaf too I don't
think she chopped it up mix it up it was
just straight hamburger meat so you
asked me questions about like did your
mom do this did your mom I wasn't eating
a whole bunch of it so I don't know
that's cool you know what I mean hit me
with some chicken nuggies and some mac
and cheese your bird throw out a decent
meatloaf down here oh yeah except for
one year she went vegetarian against the
little the whole family and put out a
lentil loaf that almost started a
revolution
burn the witch
a lentil loaf I bet you've done right
it's probably not bad and the word on
the street is your mom's a pretty good
cook probably does it nice those vegan
foods are pretty good
they're not bad sure
um
yeah well Atlanta loaf is a tough look I
feel could be let's call it something
else yeah they shouldn't do that like
they shouldn't one time we can't meet
first of all meatloaf is a tough
combination of words meatloaf the only
reason where it's okay it rolls off the
toes is because we're used we're
conditioned to hear it you just put loaf
on the end of anything else you don't
want it big 50s thing everything was a
loaf yeah because the [ __ ] husbands
are working and the moms are all on
pills
in the 50s oh yeah [ __ ] they were
[ __ ] lewds messed all nine yards to
the Sackler family yeah let's go ahead
of the Curve
keeping the good times going
um
ah [ __ ] what was I gonna say oh yeah one
time we had we have loaf on the brain oh
I got loaf on the brain we had um we
went up to Sleepy Hollow one time we
went to this vegetarian or vegan
restaurant and we had uh vegan buffalo
wings which is tempeh you know what
tempeh is it's like soy compressed
together sure it's awesome and they were
[ __ ] awesome and the blue cheese was
awesome and it was it was fantastic
don't call it chicken wings yeah call it
something else give it stay what it is I
understand Buffalo tempeh sure you don't
need to convince us like the fake
burgers and all that stuff don't try to
do that be who you are
don't hide yourself have you ever used
meatloaf as bread on a sandwich
ah listen no I'm not a big meatloaf guy
oh that was a that was a question just
for bowling
I was trying to be polite are you
talking to me
it's a move I can see you do it 100
. better meatloaf sandwich in my day
take to take two slices of Meatloaf you
have to do it while it's cold so this is
the next day
you slice it about the thickness of a
Texas toast okay then you put your
cheese your lunch meat your pepperoni
whatever you have in the house in there
and then you glue it like a grilled
cheese but you eat it with a knife and
fork what's your next question
I don't know we got to take your blood
pressure I'm sure though
or you just eat it cold which is pretty
good cold meatloaf the next day is great
because it's nice and firm also reminds
me of my dad like a cliff barge wait why
I used to just eat cold stuff out of the
fridge in a really turns the best
the best O'Connor knows what's up he
eats cold cold lasagna I understand it
now as I'm older but you know I have a I
prefer it sometimes sure plus too is to
heat it up
let's go there we go all right so I ate
some stir fry some turkey stir fry that
we got a Trader Jews
okay got the bird maid next day it was
gone right out of the thing ice cold
picked up on that delicious
um all right this one's from scir
is it garbage to pre-weigh your airplane
luggage on the scale at the supermarket
saw two people doing this at Publix and
immediately thought of you guys what the
[ __ ]
you're stop just do it there in front of
the people yeah but then you got a gym
what if you don't have you know what if
what if it's too much or whatever yeah
then you just take which is another
garbage thing if you're there if you
have to open your luggage at the airport
I saw that I've done it and I I
literally almost led to a divorce
I'm not even [ __ ] around my my wife
is going back to Germany with like a
bunch of I forget what it was Beatles
tapes and blue jeans
they're real into Levi's
[Laughter]
I think she was Cigarettes and Chocolate
try to sneak him over at Checkpoint
Charlie I think she was here for like
six months and then going home before
she finally moved here and it was like
she had so much stuff and I was [ __ ]
dude we're there with like multiple and
it wasn't like she came in at like 52
and a half pounds she came in at like 88
so I have dude I was cat take that
microwave out what are you doing I was
like taking one shoe leaving the other
like it was a it was a chaos I was that
guy sweating that's a tough but stop it
at a grocery store on your way to the
airport listen is Ultimate trash I mean
we've bought in Scales I remember when
you have one right here yeah I mean
[ __ ] Toby weighs the luggage every
time we go on the road there you go
that's kind of sad that's the same scale
you used the way me but yeah I mean we
literally I literally bought that off
like
an A Farm website
there was a horse on the cover of the
Box mules are us
uh that was gonna do well
I get it man I I you know it's not it's
definitely not classy but it's like
yeah I guess go by scale but if you're
gonna go buy a scale why don't you be
like I'll pay the extra [ __ ] fifty
dollars and you know can you just walk
it where's their scales at grocery
stores what do you go to the loading
dock I thought there's like one of those
questions
I'm sure for maybe like the recite a lot
of places have like different a lot of
places outside New York and the region
have other kind of things going on like
the propane [ __ ] tanks and the ice
outside yeah those propane tanks always
scared me outside all locked up
you put that [ __ ] in the back I get so
nervous hooking those up I don't know
why I've never had a bad experience but
I'm just like man this could go south oh
[ __ ] blow your whole [ __ ]
everything off y'all want my what get
out of here stand back
you hear that hiss I get nervous too
when I'm lighting up the grill and I
smell the I smell the propane and the
[ __ ] thing's not going but I think I
got about 0.2 seconds where I take out
the whole neighborhood I've had that
blow in my family I didn't I had to
leave Oppenheimer I had the lid down or
something me and my friends were
grilling at an age where we were drunk
and shouldn't have been grilling they're
like 17 or 16 or something and my buddy
is like I'm like oh let me it was closed
so it all the gas build up
dude I opened it and he had pressed it
and it clicked dude we [ __ ] hit the
deck dude it was a [ __ ] scene Stakes
with no eyebrows
pretty good huh
shout out to Chad we almost lost you
that day Chad uh this one's from Jackson
is it garbage to set your cars clocks
set ahead seven minutes so you're never
late no do the same thing with the with
the oven
I love that move I hate that move I
don't think it makes sense you know who
did that a lot who she didn't set the
clocks but she would come in and say it
was a certain time when it was really
that's different 20 minutes it's already
7 30. get up you're gonna be late yeah
you [ __ ] wake up you [ __ ] panicked
[ __ ] Splash from cold water in your
face you run downstairs [ __ ] Good
Morning America around yeah it's like
[ __ ] 6 30. that I get a winner sets
his clock ahead so he's never late I
like that
I like that thing yeah it is no you look
at all the successful people in the
world I guarantee you the clock in their
microwave is 15 minutes fast so they're
out the door and at the meeting on time
no if they're either your 15 minutes
early or you're 15 minutes late buddy
if you want to work if you want to work
at this company pay it right now
by this logic you're late first of all
you're late more than everybody by this
logic it's the microwave that makes that
kind of microwave
it's the microwave that makes them
successful if that was just regular time
they would just be like hanging
sheetrock somewhere yeah oh no hanging
sheet rocks uh quality job I'm not
saying it's not but I would argue that's
not one of the most successful things no
it's my family if you don't set your
clock
15 minutes ahead you're sitting around
you're smoking doobies and you're
playing video games okay that's how it
goes I like all of those things
sometimes you high right now
and I think I'm hanging some Sheetrock
later to be honest with you my my
stepdad used to do it and and always
yeah hold on you ever see those guys
that are really good at that sheetrock
oh yeah literally most of my family are
like apers [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] put it
up and everything looks so clean I wish
I could do construction that's my one
because I got that stuff he doesn't even
hate just tapes he's a really good taper
like they're doing the seams he just
goes in and just [ __ ] once it's all
hung he's like I guess the special you
know yeah get out of my way let me do it
let me do my master hey bring him in
he's going down at the lunch truck
smoking heaters [ __ ] rapping with
broads right you're up yeah comes in hey
honey hold my Red Bull I'll be back in
five minutes I like it
um this one's hit me Phil McCracken 10
board member here is a garbage if I'm 41
years old and my biological father is
still paying me child support
bonus garbage points for using the
monthly payments to buy a hundred and
twenty dollars in scratch offs every
month man how's that legal how's what
legal but you still pay child support
when the kid's 41. probably didn't pay
it when he was zero through 18 if I
assumed okay so he's owed I'm making up
a number 50 000. that's how it's done
yeah and you have to pay that back you
have pay back child support you have to
pay so he's owed that money so if I had
a kid I believe that's all worth so if I
had a kid didn't pay any child wouldn't
it get you eventually yeah they got him
yeah so you'd hold it off you can only
afford 120 to pay 120 a month so you
have to pay that whatever it is if it's
10 grand 100 grand 50 Grand I like what
he's using it for that's good real [ __ ]
you to the old man damn what do you mean
[ __ ] you that's a retirement right there
no I'm still in a life [ __ ] you how's it
bad like yeah I'm taking your child
support you never paid me and I'm buying
scratchers with what do you think about
that
[Music]
yeah yeah very garbage but smart move I
like it I used to have to be the
middleman with the check really I'll be
like ask your father about that check
yeah
what's a big headed kid like you worth
in the open market in the 90s
it was a lot if it was more than 37
cents I'd be stunning it was it was a
lot things were going well back then
yeah for the fam yikes and they all
crumbled uh that payment still stays the
same yeah which you know caught a little
resentment day
[Laughter]
is that little [ __ ] yeah digging in the
lunch meat this guy's 1200 bucks a month
get the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] kids eating all my goddamn
goldfish
so what did you call juice boxes we were
sips even though they weren't the name
brand sips I see called him high C even
if they weren't High C's they usually
were yeah they usually were I remember
she tried to send me an orange Sip and
it was a high C do you remember those
Adam and Eve ones that they had what the
[ __ ] was kind of freaky [ __ ] you got
going on over there what was it called
Adam and something I think it was Adam
and Eve oh but that was like the hell
Adam's Harvest or something that yeah
whatever it was they were there you you
had you had [ __ ] Adam and Eve I would
just throw that [ __ ] out of the [ __ ]
cart when she wasn't looking it was like
the organic whatever stuff there's like
a Skyline or a farm it wasn't organic it
was just less sugar that was it was
shittier yeah they sucked Adam's Farm
I got apple and Eve apple and Eve yeah
and clearly that's it
that's the that's that apple juice we've
been calling Adam and Eve is Apple and
Eve yes that'll be get this kid a raise
cross-reference that will you I want to
be sure yeah [ __ ] all that stuff
he's gonna got nothing maybe an apple we
didn't get sips the the I the Iced Teas
yeah the sips Iced Teas in the Black Box
those things cooked and so we were we
were our iced tea was wow iced tea but
we
called them sit oh juice what flavor
sips were you getting we know we're
getting high we were getting a high sea
juice boxes okay but we called them sips
go get me an orange sip get me a fruit
punch sip like Danny liked fruit punch I
was an orange man and we very rarely
crossed pollinate those orange and if we
did headlocks ensues
and then he would hurt me and then my
dad would hurt him as a circle of
islands
all over a sip all over me taking a
fruit punch man I mean I've ruined
Sundays over a [ __ ] Kudos bar those
days you just wake up and you're like
you're you you and the brother are just
bumping ahead you're like oh this is
it's gonna turn this this is gonna
culminate at some point yeah oh yeah
usually right before dinner they're
cooking all day it ruins dinner then you
just have dinner and quiet and everybody
cries and says they're sorry then you
watch Married with Children and go to
bed we would get a lot my mom would like
give up right you know at a certain age
where she's just like they're not you
know we were just fighting sure um you
guys are what three years apart four
years apart four five four I think yeah
close up close to five that's why you're
a tough kid that was that that was a
that was a tough road a hoe five years
difference he was a grown man at that
point I think he was born in 82 and I
was 86 so yeah I think it was like four
yeah that's why me and my brother 18
months apart we were [ __ ] neck and
neck no no yeah he was it was he always
had he always had the physical Advantage
uh see that's courage right there
knowing you're gonna take a beating you
still you still steal the fruit punch
[ __ ] I never [ __ ] you hit me and I tell
you what it was worth it you're sipping
the last sip you hear the gurgling yeah
and I'm gonna pop it later
um that's great well we would get uh
um you're a high C family my dad okay
yeah was the Peace scoring juice boxes
for you no that was like yeah no maybe
Capri Suns at a certain things were
going well at a certain time period
first but we crushed those those if I
was having a [ __ ] peanut butter
sandwich I was crushing five [ __ ] I
was crushing half a box of pretty
squeezing squeeze I had strong hands
the Capri Sun might as well that might
as well have been [ __ ] Platinum there
was no way 0.75 ounces is the standard I
don't know why I know that I've drank a
lot of sips but
we would get but me and my brother were
fighting it was my dad's night my my mom
he would come pick us up after work at
like whether you know it would be like
four or six because like the ball we
after school we go back to my mom's and
then on those days
he would pick us up after during the
week yeah would you could drop back off
that night
no he would take me to school the next
morning okay it's just we his house was
like 10 minutes away or five minutes
away from my mom's but public we didn't
want to switch schools sure so public
transported like the public trans I
wasn't taking the L train [ __ ] the
bus wouldn't take us to his neighborhood
it would just still drop us off at my
mom okay she would pick us up after work
gotcha until the Danny and Sarah started
driving whatever we digress but when we
got we would be my mom would be like I'm
[ __ ] calling your father
which is like like it was like it was
our equivalent of wait till your dad
gets home oh [ __ ] yeah of course well we
had the weird I'm calling your father
but traffic he won't be here for 15
minutes but then he would pull up and
that walk to the car like he would pull
up
to pick us up anyway so you caused some
[ __ ] we called she called him calls him
at three your sons are [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then he's like well I'll be over
five or whatever
now walk to that car you're not sure
what you're getting dude
it was it well you get in it would be
all cool and you're like I want this is
gonna go south I prefer when is it going
south I used to prefer the straight to
violence of course that's what you want
but we would strategically sit in the
car to like because I'm like I know he's
not gonna climb minimize the pinches
well me and Danny are now on the same
team you know what I mean we're like my
enemy's enemy exactly there's bigger
fish to fry than a [ __ ] Juice Box you
know you got piano wire and [ __ ] I'm
behind them not tonight not tonight
throw flowers in it flower in his eyes
that's [ __ ] wild yeah yeah I remember
you get behind them we won't be able to
get you and he's probably not gonna hit
me I'm too young man you can make a lot
of room in those back bucket seats it
was a Jeep too
I've just all been in another [ __ ]
jurisdiction
from an international waters decade good
luck getting me Nothing's Gonna stick
but yeah I remember my dad coming home a
few times looking back this [ __ ] poor
guy [ __ ] coming home exhausted
[ __ ] and just
and I would prefer when he would just
snap just to get it out of the way
because sometimes he'd ice you for a
little while and he'd be waiting for him
to make a move and if he didn't make a
move
you'd maybe start running a little lip
again if it was being discussed openly
well he did this and maybe ah what the
[ __ ] I didn't do that and then you'd get
one yeah well you're nuts oh man that's
like that's that's like the jury's got
the jury's letting you go and then you
chime in and be like I also called her a
fat pig you're like what the [ __ ] that's
a provoked shark attack yeah that's
that's exactly what that is
you're nuts
well I didn't see because if he didn't
make a move early you think oh he's not
going to make a move
they're restoring their energy you know
what I mean you ever seen a dad angrily
eat his dinner after the family had
eaten their dinner like he gets home
later and he's eating his dinner and
[ __ ] can't even enjoy it because he
knows he gotta [ __ ] do a little ass
whooping after
yeah I think that's that's fatherhood I
think for most people or it wasn't the
[ __ ] shout out to the 90s it's a
different time back then good time
um
man that's a tough one
um all right let's do one more then we
gotta get out of this one's uh
uh his patreon name is Foley's
accountant which on the patreon it's
this guy you got to get a new account
screwing me yeah uh have you ever run a
garden hose up to the second floor
window just so you didn't have to go
down to the kitchen when you want to
drink at night what the [ __ ] then in
parentheses this ends with the neighbor
coming over a few days later to ask if
everything was okay
that's nuts
that's nuts man that's like plus I don't
know about it looks like you're running
a grow operation or something yeah
that's no good the snow's melted on top
of one spot in the house that's a real
suspect yeah that's [ __ ] must have
been some good hose water tell you that
shout out to hose water shout out to it
fantastic but I preferred in the middle
of the night to let the water run in the
bathroom
okay in the sink and I'll tell you
something else too nothing gets colder
in the winter time than the water coming
out of the [ __ ] tub
I [ __ ] I've drank out of that before
that's that's like [ __ ] Fiji Water
Ice Cold from the mountains it felt like
it came do you go to bed with water now
oh what am I in a sitcom
but I'll tell you if you go to bed with
a with some water of course yeah you do
that's a Seinfeld bit you bring a cup of
water into bed with you well if we're
being honest I have a I sleep in the
kitchen
[Laughter]
I I'll have like you know two-thirds of
a Seltzer I'm sipping on it and put it
on the floor next to my bed probably all
right I'll give you that that's in the
dirt ball realm insane dude how warm
that is in the middle of the night I
love it sometimes you're eating a
firecracker yeah but the the bubbles go
away and you can get it down quicker I
tell you chat down you know what's real
I'm going to rate it flat soda flat
soda's all right well I'd say it's all
right what the [ __ ] was that
is good sometimes okay it's delicious
sure all right I think that's okay
you're taking a glass of water to bed
with you bottle glass yeah really every
night and we're very parched and you
wake up in another night and have it
there yeah or in the morning yeah but
yeah I'll typically take a sip you know
what saved me the other night that
liquid IV because [ __ ] I had one and
I don't know if it did this week I had
that I had it in a thermos
with that the ice cubes are still in it
and like like my girl's water bottle
and we went out to Bluebell in that
night I got all [ __ ] up middle of the
night I woke up [ __ ] just hung over
and whatever opened that thing up yeah
[ __ ] slammed it do it right back to
night night we gotta wrap it up gang we
[ __ ] love you to death come see a
[ __ ] live show shows are [ __ ]
we're moving some [ __ ] tickets moving
some tickets they're good times and
we're coming [ __ ] a lot of spots yeah
tell some friends share the show we love
you bring the bozos bring the homies we
love you and we'll see you next week